interdit aux voitures jusqu'à 20 heures
rue des étalages du quartier de
l'université fonds faite depuis ce matin
aux piétons 1971 c'est une première à
lyon la ville teste la piétonnisation
d'un de ces quartiers les commerçants et
des piétons sont alors les premiers avis
est ce que vous avez fait de meilleures
affaires depuis ce matin j'ai doublé mes
affaires si pour certains l'expérience
est une réussite
d'autres au contraire n'hésite pas à
manifester leur mécontentement
toutes les rues sont bouchés on peut pas
on ne peut pas du tout car et on peut
voir passer il faut faire un tour énorme
alors on s'en va en 1975 la
piétonnisation de lyon prend un
véritable tournant
suite à la construction du métro la rue
de la république principale artère
commerçante de la ville devient alors la
première rythme entièrement piétonne de
lyon c'est une véritable marée humaine
qui a déferlé hier dans la rue de la
république pour une inauguration peu
protocolaire mais très sympathique
le cortège officiel conduit par le maire
de lyon s'est vite noyé dans cette foule
bigarrée en délire un véritable triomphe
un an après le dispositif s'étend la rue
victor-hugo réputé aussi pour ses
commerces devient à son tour piétonne en
1984 andré soulier adjoint au maire de
lyon dresser un bilan de cette
piétonnisation on peut assister ici à
lyon comme dans d'autres villes à une
volonté de refaire des places et toulon
projet urbain désormais sont fondés sur
la reconquête de ces espaces pour que
les gens s'associent par la conversation
par la promenade par la flânerie
si la piétonnisation de lyon a débuté
dans les années 70
d'autres quartiers sont devenus piétons
depuis parmi eux la place des capucins
le secteur non c'est ou encore la place
saint jean
[Musique]